but it's also sad when you realize
Donald Trump was President we had no new
Wars he leaves everything's falling
apart the Abraham Accords are basically
gone Israel Gaza all that conflict
Ukraine China has deployed warships
surrounding Taiwan Venezuela is going to
make a move on Guyana World War III may
be on the horizon houthi Rebels are
shutting down one of the most prominent
shipping lanes in the world to the Red
Sea and none of this is happening when
Trump's president maybe because why
Trump threatened to Nuke people is that
it well you've also got ecoas popping
off there in West Africa as well you've
got ecoas and the ecoas alliance with
Nigeria and those other countries uh
they were threatening with uh what is it
Burkina Faso Mali and I can't remember
the Third Country there oh wow that
could pop off as well well I realize it
was that bad lost all hope it's
everywhere well hopefully you know this
is a fourth times the charm Trump
finally gets Nobel Peace Prize